most people know that Apple MacBook
laptops are more expensive than many of
the windows options and a lot of Windows
laptops pack better performance specs
while being cheaper but for some reason
a lot of people are choosing to pay
hundreds of dollars more for a MacBook
so why is that and why have we seen so
many Mac users who switch to good
Windows laptops because of Apple's high
prices go back after just a few months
and if you're not a fan of Apple devices
hold on just a second before you dislike
this video and leave because chances are
there are probably a few good reasons
that you've never thought about here are
18 reasons why Mac books are so
expensive let's start off with the
hardware most people who have used a
macbook trackpad would agree that
apple's force touch trackpad are by far
the best you can get
they don't actually move or click they
use a pane of glass with sensors
underneath that sense pressure from your
finger and the taptic engine below it
vibrates to give you haptic feedback
that feels like a click so you can get a
perfect clicking feel anywhere you press
and it can even sense pressure for 3d
touch these awesome track pads cost much
more than the plastic ones with Springs
and other Windows laptops Apple also
uses really fine-tuned high quality
speakers that sound incredible impact a
lot of volume for the size just listen
to this comparison between Apple's 2017
MacBook Pro and Dells newest 2019 XPS 13
[Music]
and as you've just heard the MacBook
Pros speakers sound much better in every
single way and check out that same
MacBook Pros microphone quality compared
to the same dell XPS this is a
microphone quality test on the MacBook
Pro this is a microphone quality tests
on the Dell XPS 13 yep there's a huge
difference and that's something you
can't see on a spec sheet Apple also
packs in additional custom chips that
weren't cheap to develop like Apple's t2
chip which gives extra features like
added security through the secure
enclaves and to end encryption and
things like HD VC encoding making a huge
difference in encoding speed although
macbook displays might not be the
highest resolution out there Apple's
displays are much brighter than the
average windows laptop and they also use
very high quality coatings that reduce
reflectivity by a lot so they're much
easier to use in bright conditions or
outside MacBook Pros are also incredibly
color accurate supporting p3 white color
gamut which has around 25% more colors
compared to srgb one thing that many
people don't consider is that Apple's
MacBooks are machined out of a solid
block of aluminum which is not only
expensive for the materials alone but
also more costly to manufacture but
result in a very solid chassis with a
premium feel because of this Apple is
able to create custom stacks of
batteries that are sized perfectly to
fit the interior of the aluminum chassis
so we get more battery life out of very
thin laptops but they do cost a lot more
than standard batteries and before
number-9 let's talk about our sponsor
Squarespace it's never been so easy to
create your own website there's a huge
variety of templates to choose from and
it's so easy that I personally created
this business site in no time just click
to add basically anything from image
galleries two buttons in e-commerce
products and then you can easily arrange
them so make it with Squarespace
checkout squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to Squarespace comm slash Mac stack to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain every single Mac book
since 2013 pack top-of-the-line SSD
flash storage while there are still some
Windows laptops out there to this day
that come with really slow physical hard
drives and if they do come with SSDs
many times they're nowhere near as fast
as Apple's SSDs on top of that they give
you the option to spec up to four
terabytes of extremely fast
storage while many windows laptops are
limited to much less but admittedly the
prices are really marked up and you'll
end up with a crazy expensive laptop
Apple's MacBook Pros also feature more
Thunderbolt 3 ports than you can get on
Windows laptops there are currently no
Windows laptops that we know of that
have for full speed Thunderbolt 3 ports
like the 15-inch MacBook Pro does and
that requires extra Thunderbolt chips
from Intel although not everybody likes
apples touch bar and we're personally
not fans they're still incredibly high
quality touch screen OLED displays
packing touch ID with end-to-end
encryption which adds on extra cost
compared to Windows laptops and speaking
of encryption let's move on to software
Apple focuses on privacy making
everything on your MacBook as secure as
possible and they never sell any of your
data like some other companies do so
they have to earn their full profit from
the laptop itself Apple's Mac OS is only
available in Apple devices so that
allows them to charge more for their
laptops since if you need Mac OS there's
no competition on the windows laptop
side there are a lot more manufacturers
so they have to lower their prices to
compete since Mac OS is only available
on a small number of machines this
limited number of components means that
apps and drivers are very optimized to
make the most out of the hardware
because of this software issues are less
common and old machines still run fast
which really improves resale value
meaning Apple can charge more for new
ones with Mac OS you also get free major
updates every single year whereas when a
new version of Windows comes out you
have to pay for it along with that when
you buy a MacBook you get a lot of
workflow apps that are similar to
Microsoft Word PowerPoint and Excel and
Microsoft charges for all of those on
top of your laptop purchase it's nice to
have those for free including any future
updates but this does contribute to
higher base laptop prices and finally
let's touch on customer service Apple is
the only laptop manufacturer that has
thousands of physical stores all over
the world which makes it much easier to
get support or repairs and they even
have a no-questions-asked 14 day return
policy without any return shipping costs
or other fees returns aren't as easy
with Windows laptops in a lot of them
charged 15% restocking fees Apple
doesn't do that so they take the loss
themselves there's no question that
Apple laptops cost a lot more money but
hopefully this video helped you to see a
few reasons why that price is often
higher than the competition
judging off the spec sheet often
times we are shocked by what Apple
charges for the base CPU and GPU spec
but once you compare the hardware
software and all the little details that
you won't see on the spec sheet it
starts to make a lot more sense of
course not everyone cares for these
included features so less expensive and
more customizable Windows laptop still
appeals to a lot of people out there and
to them the higher price of a macbook is
not worth it let us know your thoughts
down in the comment section below make
sure to tap that like button and click
the circle above to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]